uh look the areas that have been
mentioned today in the press briefing
including bolton
are absolutely areas of concern
for now and um i would advise the
residents in those areas
to think very carefully about the
freedoms they have
weigh up the risks and be very cautious
so if it is possible to do something
outside
better to do it outside it if it is
possible to do
something with smaller numbers with
people you know rather than multiple new
contacts
it's better to do that take it steady
i think i've said don't tear the pants
out of it once before from
this or a similar podium but frankly
we're back to that again now
um the government has given people
freedoms to start to make these
judgments
for themselves and i understand that you
know we can't live
for years and years on end with rules
you know people will have to learn to
manage these risks from covid
for themselves because this is not going
to go away
in the short term the medium term and
probably the long term
but you have to be cautious you have to
weigh it up
really carefully and if you don't feel
well
you need to absolutely get a test if
you're offered a test
as part of the surge testing you need to
have it
you need to follow the rules on
isolation and
when you get the call for the vaccine
whether it's your first dose or your
second
remember this is a race against the
transmissibility of the virus
don't delay take up the offer come
forwards immediately